okay
let me start with the agenda of
tomorrow's college meeting
the college will adopt an eu strategy
for continued coved 19 control
measures commissioner stella kiriakidis
will present this communication during
the press conference
following the video conference of health
ministers tomorrow afternoon
then the college will also adopt a joint
communication
on a new eu us agenda for global change
high representative vice president
joseph borrel will present this to you
in more detail tomorrow in a press
conference
after the college meeting here in the
context of the college readout
the college will also discuss the
european democracy action plan
and the strategy to strengthen the
application of the charter of
fundamental rights in the eu
vice president vera yorova will give a
press conference on thursday
on both these files
the commissioners will also adopt an
action plan to support the recovery and
transformation of the media
and audio visual sectors and furthermore
the college
will also adopt a package of documents
and measures
on the digitalization of justice in the
eu
and a new strategy on european judicial
training
now let me call balaj for an
announcement on
sure
good afternoon so today the european
commission has disbursed 8.5 billion
euros to five member states under the
shore
program in this third installment of
financial support
belgium has received 2 billion euro
hungary
200 million portugal 3 billion
romania 3 billion and slovakia 300
million
these loans are granted on favorable
terms and they will help these member
states
to address sudden increases in public
expenditure to preserve
employment the commission has so far
proposed to make
90.3 billion euro in financial support
available
to 18 member states the next
disbursements will take place
in the course of the next month now more
information on this topic
is available in our press release online
uh
good afternoon this morning high
representative
burrell co-chaired the 23rd eu
asean ministerial meeting via video
conference
alongside uh singapore's minister of
foreign affairs dr vivian
balakrishan as country coordinator for
asian eu dialogue relations
the meeting was attended by the foreign
ministers from all asian
and eu member states the leaders agreed
to upgrade relations elevating the asean
eu dialogue partnership to a strategic
partnership
which will provide important support for
effective multilateralism
and international cooperation in the
current global landscape and noted good
progress in the implementation
of the eu asian eu plan of action
2018-2022 a strategic partnership
also provides a platform for leaders
level interaction to engage our partners
in the region at the highest level
opening up
a regular opportunity for summit level
talks in
with asia the eu now joins china
japan republic of korea india australia
us new zealand and russia are strategic
partners
of asean the leaders also reconfirmed
their determination to work together
among others
to fight covet 19 pandemic strengthening
both regions preparedness
and ensuring fair equitable and
affordable access to safe and effective
vaccines
to strengthen our economic linkages to
bolster
the 19 recovery to continue
engaging and cooperating in wider
asia-pacific and india
indian oceans regions to strengthen
connectivity and cooperation in cyber
security
the leaders reaffirmed their commitment
to tackle the urgent
challenge of climate change protect
biodiversity and work together
in reachable sustainable development
goals a joint statement was issued after
the meeting and is available
online during the ministerial meeting
commissioner for international
partnerships utah europa linen
also announced a new 20 million
programme to support the preparedness
and response
capacities to covet 19 of our asian
partners
a press release is also online thank you
thank you very much
president
remedy
and i'm glad to welcome back atanacios
good afternoon
i have a question because you mentioned
the vice president europa
and i'm a little bit puzzled with an
answer she gave yesterday
to some members of the european
parliament during a debate
apparently she put in the same basket
greece hungary and poland
concerning
the greek government has distributed to
a series of
news outlets as an answer
to the economic crisis created by the
pandemic
buck in spring and summer early summer
was it
so what exactly did it mean by
piling up greece hungary and poland
concerning rule of law issues
in relevance to the present press
freedom
was it accurate what we have read in
some
press releases by mep's quoting
this categorization that the vice
president
has made or is it something else thank
you
thank you attenacios we lost part of
your introductory remarks but i believe
that
christian has is aware of the issue
and has heard in any case the question
which you've asked so he will be able to
answer
yes indeed thank you ethanol
look uh we have seen some some
misleading reporting actually about an
internal meeting
with meps as you as you know we do not
comment of course on internal meetings
in general
let me however clarify that vice
president europa did not
comment on the situation in greece
specifically
let me refer you rather to our rule of
law report
which she also highlighted which called
for all member states
uh that it's important to have a
transparent fair allocation of state
advertising that procurement rules
i should respect it and that eu money
should be spent
uh correctly so the position in our
report
laid out in a report is very clear and i
would not
comment any further on on content of
internal
discussions thank you very much
christian
since christian is on the podium are
there other rule of law questions for us
today please keep your hand raised only
if it is
on the rule of law
atanasius you have a follow-up
yes i have a follow-up because christian
mentioned that it's uh it was an
internal
discussion why then was it
even published by the meps
thank you
sorry i think that's it that's the
question for the meps uh this was
supposed to be an internal
working meeting and such internal
working meetings
are not public
is it some kind of bridge of trust
that's what i mean
we're not going to comment on that we
we've seen we've seen indeed that there
was
uh that there was uh some comments on
what was discussed during that meeting
but we will go no further
than what christian has said has said
now
moses you have a question on the rule of
law
moses you have the floor
but you need to press speak
now go ahead okay thank you
yes this question concerns angry and the
rule of law there
and what have been written in hungarian
newspapers about the eurozones
also by the hungarian prime minister i
think last week
it seemed to me a kind of conspiracy
conspiracy theory
where he talks who writes about the kind
of network
uh led by your source which has
engaged also high-ranking ale democrats
in order to create what he calls the
global empire this seems to be
a conspiracy theory fake news and i
wonder if the commission
plans some way to contradict or count to
this
as indeed i remember last year during
the
election campaign in hungary
when there were similar claims about
fake claims about it's immigration
policy
thank you christian
look i think in general
we have been always clear and relentless
in
dispelling distorted information half
grooves
conspiracy theories so of course
facts effects matter and when the
commission
and and our work is being
distorted then we also always reserve
the right
to to clarify the facts and
to ensure that citizens
are are informed correctly i'm now not
aware in detail of the latest of the
latest
comments that you mentioned but i mean
clearly
we do not
we work we work also in general um
as johannes can of course explain to you
in much more more detail
on countering this information and you
will see also some
of these of these issues reflected in
our upcoming european democracy
action plan which will be discussed
in the college this week thank you
christian are there other questions on
the rule of law
for us today that does not seem to be
the case
so i opened the floor to other issues
and david you had a question
[Music]
um i can i can put it in english
i've seen that the the commission has uh
approved the head stated for post
italian
for the universal service at the same
time
post italiane is buying
the second biggest postal group in italy
nexiv i'm wondering
since the amount uh granted
by italy and approved today and
um since
this this acquisition by by post italian
i'm wondering if do you see any kind of
problem with post italiana thank you
oh yeah
thanks eric and uh thanks david so
indeed
today we have approved a compensation
for
um post italiane by italy for the
fulfillment of its
public service obligation for the period
from 2020 until 2024.
you know public service mission also
called
uzo is the fulfillment of the delivery
services uh by post italiane
five days a week in the entire territory
of of the country
and what we look at in these cases is
that there is no overcompensation so to
ensure
that prostate italiana gets the right
amount of aid for the service
it has to provide based on its public
service obligation
i will have to get back to you on the
acquisition
because i need to check if it has been
notified to us or or not
as always you know that it's up to the
companies to notify transactions to the
commission
if they indeed have an eu dimension but
i'm very happy to check this and then
get back to you on that
thank you ayanna are there other
competition related questions
for ariana today
alexander you have a competition
question
no sorry my question concerns uh
concerning something else sorry
highly surprised indeed okay um
other competition questions
that does not seem to be the case thank
you very much ayanna so i opened the
floor
to other issues
um and tommaso was the first to have
raised his hand previously so tommaso
you have the floor
yes thank you very much good morning and
thank you for the question er
it's a question on the mff because i've
read that
the commission told to the ambassador
that
if there is no deal on the mff
the expenditure would be the loss in
expenditure would be
roughly 25 30 billion euros per year
i wonder if you can confirm that number
which is i mean
it's just an indication but just to have
an idea
of the amount that you're going to risk
to lose
thank you thank you tommaso i'm i'm not
going to start commenting on
um on discussions that uh the
commission is having with different
actors not today at least but it is
um it is clear we have said here on the
podium
many times that if there is no agreement
then clearly um the treaties foresee
that um we the eu would have to operate
under this regime of the so-called
provisional 12th
and the regime of the provisional 12th
foresees obviously very strict limits
as to the type of expenditure that can
be financed
and also the level of of expenditure and
this would
necessarily imply significant cuts
compared to what we have foreseen in the
mff
and with the top-ups foreseen by next
generation eu
but of course the exact figures will
depend
um will depend on exactly the situation
that we are in at the beginning of next
year so
um for the moment i would not want to
comment on specific comments but i
um i can i can definitely concur
that there would be cuts in the level of
expenditure
significant cuts compared to to what we
would have
foreseen if the mff and next generation
u
are adopted as foreseen
are there other questions uh for us
today
on the issue of the budget
please only keep your hand raised if it
is the case
jacobo is your question on the budget
no it's about another thing okay then
hold on please
david
uh
[Music]
uh
raised if it is on the budget jakub i
know it's not on the budget so i will
not give you the floor for the moment
but you have a question on the budget
you have the floor uh is there a
deadline for the budget
2021 sorry we didn't hear the beginning
of your question
is there a deadline for the budget 2021.
do you mean in terms of the process to
have this
budget i can hear a lot of background
noise but if you could cut your yeah
sorry
thanks
i understand your question is meaning
to have a 2021 budget adopted
based on an agreed mff i would give the
floor
to balash on this
hello so on the annual budget
the agreement has to be found uh in the
context of the consolation procedure
which started on the 17th of november
and is due to finish by the seventh uh
of of december so that's where the
annual budget
um is is being discussed but of course
for us to have been on your budget we
also need to have
an mff
okay um thank you other questions for us
on the budget i do not see any so i go
back
to alexander who had raised his hand
quite some time ago alexander
hello thanks for taking the question um
yeah i just wanted to
ask about the european democracy action
plan
which i understand is set to be
presented tomorrow but apparently
there's some confusion we're hearing
that the presentation might be pushed
back to thursday and i just wanted to
clarify
uh when are you going to present and uh
yeah and just maybe a few words under on
the process
thank you alexander i believe i made
that very clear
during my announcements at the beginning
of the midday briefing indeed
this is a file which will be discussed
by the college
tomorrow and will be presented by
vice president eurova on thursday this
is something that we regularly do
as you know when we have numerous points
on the college agenda and that we cannot
present them all on the same on the same
day
you have a follow-up
yes thanks uh so will the
um text of the actual communication be
available tomorrow or will that also be
pushed back to thursday
normally they will be pushed back to uh
they will be pushed back to thursday
for uh to allow for the presentation of
the
of the package so the formal adoption
would be on thursday uh this is my
understanding
all right i now move to
jacobo
jakubo you have the floor
you need to press the speak button
which is easily identifiable i think on
your screen
go ahead yeah you were there
i know it's the first time that you're
connecting
but you were there
[Applause]
[Applause]
official
um
j
[Music]
du language on the chat
nicolas
monroe
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
yes you have the floor
at least i saw that you had asked for
the floor
go ahead you're connected at least i can
see you
cannot hear you though you seem to have
a problem with your mic source sorry
try again
okay yeah go ahead
yes uh i wanted to ask about the vaccine
approval
we saw that the ema announced that it
received the the applications of both
moderna
and pfizer biontech today uh the rolling
review process for pfizer
began more than a month earlier than
what they're not does that mean we
should expect
the pfizer vaccine to be approved
earlier than moderna
thank you i believe that this is really
a question
for emma but perhaps stefan has other
other information to give to you
uh indeed uh thank you very much for
this question but um
the requests for condition marketing
authorization have been done by these
companies
to the european medicine agency and the
european medicine agency that will do
the assessment
of the effectiveness and the safety of
these vaccines it is true
that for these two companies rolling
reviews had started
but what this means in terms of the
actual
delays for approval or time needed for
approval i believe the european medicine
agency is far better placed to give
an assessment of that as they are an
independent agency doing this
scientific assessment so thank you
thank you so let's stick with a few
questions related to
health and vaccines please only keep
your hand raised if it is
on this and i give the floor to griselda
merci merci beaucoup
[Music]
is
um
vaccinations
foreign
yes uh thank you and sorry for uh
abusing of your patience but it's just a
question on the vaccine
uh against kobe 19 developed by fighter
biontech
i i guess you won't be able to say
to tell much about this but i wonder if
you have taken into consideration
the fact that the pfizer ceo albert
sold a sizable amount of shares this the
very same day in which the company
announced the good results for uh for
the vaccine
uh it's not too indulging in conspiracy
theories but
i just know if you considered also this
aspect
in your dealings with that company thank
you
thank you i think that i would not
confuse
two issues tommaso one
the the work that we are doing on
developing
a portfolio of vaccines and then their
authorization
through through emma and then market
dealings by by companies
we have been negotiating as you know
contracts with
with different companies over the past
uh over the past months
and now some of those vaccines are
starting to ask
for authorization market authorization
from uh from emma
this is a completely completely
separate track from any market
considerations
that that you raised but stefan perhaps
you want to add a word on this as well
back to you thank you uh griselda i
think you had a follow-up
and i did not see that you had raised
your hand
apologies
yes hi uh yes uh also for stefan and
following up on what
griselda also asked already i just want
to know
uh exactly as soon as it leaves the emma
until it is handed over to the authority
of the member state
can you give us a guideline an idiot's
guideline
in fact on what the commission will
exactly do you were talking about the
authorization
and you were talking about consultations
is that also with a sort of a
a vote by some uh and how does that work
and then when we get to distribution
what exactly is the commission going to
do
before they hand over to the member
states and what is the last stage of the
commission's work
in all this thank you stefan
yes thank you very much well the first
step is when the european medicine
agency has given its positive
recommendation then the decision will
take the decision
sorry the commission will take the
decision to allow putting
these vaccines on the market so that's a
commission
authorization that's done by the
commission when that authorization is
given
member states can order can place orders
with the vaccine producer
and then there's two stages which which
are very important first there is a
stage of
delivery of the vaccines to the member
states and this is a stage
for which the practical arrangements are
to be agreed upon between the member
state and the vaccine developer so
the the vaccines will be delivered
by the manufacturer to the member state
on the basis of these practical
arrangements
the second step is then that it may be
possible that within the member state
the member state may wish to
transport these vaccines from the
central hub
to new or other vaccination centers in
the member state
this is a responsibility of the member
states
now we have already in our
recommendation 15 october
drawn the attention to the importance of
being well prepared among other things
for these stages for these transport
stages for these logistical stages
this is why we made our recommendations
several recommendations to help member
states with the preparation
it is possible if needed the commission
may offer support to the member states
on these transport and logistical issues
using for instance the civil protection
mechanism so
mainly it's up to the member states to
make sure that the transport and
logistics is being organized thank you
stefan there is one point that you
raised previously which you might want
to come back on very briefly which is
the intermediary stage between
the authorization by emma and the
commission decision which is the
consultation of member
states ah yes uh before the
thank you very much billy before the
adoption decision by the commission
there is normally a commentology phase
where the decision of the committee of
the commission rather is submitted to a
standing committee with representatives
of the member states
when we have their agreement of the
member states the commission can
indeed proceed with the adoption of its
decision
thank you this is what creates the
couple of days i think that stefan was
mentioning before in particular
between the decision by emma and the
commission's decision
on the market on placement on the market
of the
of the vaccines raf you have a follow-up
thank you very fast um because i mean if
you talk to about comatology and about
these consultations and
special groups uh i seem to remember
on specific issues like gmos and all
that
then that can be a very drawn out
process
how can you assure that this will be
done swiftly and that
the member states does it need a qmv
how does that work
thank you stefan thank you
thank you very much well first i think
it's very important that um to underline
that we're all on the same
[Music]
line here both the commission and member
states have have an important interest
to making sure
that these vaccines once the green light
is given by the emma
are available quickly so that we can
quickly proceed with vaccinations so i
believe that
we are all having the same interest in
making sure that this
authorization happens very quickly in
terms of
the rules that are applicable i
understand it's qualified
majority which applies here so but again
as there is a very important interest of
all
member states and the commission to make
sure that we can quickly start the
deployment of the vaccines
i believe it should be possible to
handle this
decision on this part of the process
quickly thank you
thank you mosey on health
yes exactly i have also a follow-up
question
to stefan about the availability and the
distribution of vaccines once they will
be
approved by emma because according to
reports in media it seems that for
example
uk we receive millions of doses
quite early from i suppose production
facilities here in europe or even in
brussels
so i wonder if the commission is aware
about any problems
whether other countries have other
contracts for example the united states
and then you can see
the vaccines from fighters say before
the member states thank you
thank you very much mosey moses i'm not
going to comment on
what is happening in different other
member states like the uk
and the us of course the world is
interested in having these vaccines very
quickly
what matters to us is to make sure that
for our member states we can ensure
ensure a rapid deployment purchase and
then deployment
of vaccines and it's in order to achieve
that that we have exactly concluded
contracts with several vaccine
developers the purpose of which is to
make sure that we have
safe and effective vaccines quickly for
the member states
the actual timing depends on the
contracts with the vaccine developers
but it's in order to make sure that we
have such fast delivery
that we have concluded these contracts
thank you
thank you are there other questions for
stefan today
on vaccine or health related issues
rafaela
does it work no it does work yes hello
oh it works wonderful hello thank you
it's a question yes for stefan
and health health issue um it concerns
the question
a question on the ruling of the european
court of justice concerning cbd
cannabinoid
i was already asking two weeks ago i
think and in this
uh current ruling the court of justice
classifies
uh cannabinoid cbd as non-narcotic
so i'm just wondering what does the
ruling mean for the discussion within
the european commission
as you are and as stefan confirmed two
weeks ago
as you're reviewing whether cbd should
not be classified as a food at all but
instead
as a narcotic thank you
stefan thank you very much i don't think
i can add a lot of
of course at the core decision and we're
exhausted and seeing what extent indeed
this
influences the ongoing process but i
don't think i can give at this stage
more information than that
thank you thank you very much
i see no further hands raised on health
issues so i opened the floor
to other issues
catherine you have the floor
hi um
we could hear you but then you disappear
now we can see and hear you go ahead
no you've disappeared again
okay right i don't know what's happening
there okay so
um it's a question on justice eric
and um i
we have the the april decision um by the
european court of justice that the
commission
brought about the more than
unsatisfactory situation with the
disciplinary court in poland
questioning its uh independence
to put it mildly and the court of
justice ruled
in the commission's favor and yet
nothing has been done and
recently yesterday we see the same
disciplinary court
that should have been immediately
suspended
um according to the court of justice we
see that it is
it has requested files from
a judge adjudicating a very um
well a case that is suspected of being
very politically motivated
concerning roman gertage and i'm just
wondering uh
what the commission's response is to
this
when are they going to take action um to
if if if poland continues
uh to allow this uh court
to to judge and as we see again here in
a very very
politically motivated way
yeah thank you catherine well as you
know uh on this this matter of
criminal cases being referred to the
disciplinary chamber we have actually
sent a letter to poland on this matter
and we received the reply
which we are currently analyzing the
commission is
very concerned about recent cases
involving the lifting of immunity of
judges
by the disciplinary chamber in the
context of criminal investigation
this creates a chilling effect on
the judiciary and could hinder judicial
independence
as i just uh as you just said the
commission sought clarifications from
the polish authorities
uh on these cases commissioner render
sent the letter on the 1st of november
to his counterpart to this effect and as
mentioned we will now
swiftly analyze the reply received the
commission is monitoring
the situation on the ground very closely
and can assure you that we will not
hesitate to take legal action as
necessary
thank you christian are there other
questions
for us today
that does not seem to be the case i
thank you for your attention and see you
tomorrow for the college readout